okay so uh album officially outwin
um I'm about to announce that too okay
but it's coming out to announce
everything October yeah October we're in
October man late October bro
October man it's coming so with the last
Friday of October
so one of these days I don't drop on
Fridays either bro what do you drop
just dropped a song on a Friday albums I
never dropped the album so what are you
doing Monday Tuesday Wednesday I just
like going off cycle with my arms it's
kind of just because I do four days a
week I can't tell you yeah Kev
you're going old school going Tuesday
like back in the day we used to buy CDs
man I like how you don't you don't you
just keep asking because it's you know
what I'm saying so it's coming out on a
Tuesday nice
[Laughter]
taking it vintage old school yeah yeah I
yeah what he said but Tuesday uh uh
November 33rd you know what I'm saying
it's not a real day
not a real day
November 33rd Tuesday 2000 and 2000.
your boy hey I love your grills man are
those like obviously they're not perms
no no I'm talking about your teeth your
teeth like they're not permanent yeah
I said your teeth permanent oh teeth
your grill your teeth are they permanent
now that wood grain that's what it looks
like that wood grind on that gold [ __ ]
but you could pop those out and in and
out when you want probably yeah do you
take them I mean obviously don't say
probably can you take them out I should
be able to
do you go to sleep with those in your
mouth whenever I lay down like
like your dentist is not happy with you
right now if you if if those aren't
permanent you should take them things
out I don't go to the dentist I go to
the Tooth Fairy
um
I see what you did there so what you're
saying is you're losing a lot of teeth
as a grown man nah nah as a young man
I'm guiding teeth
like a baby or some [ __ ]
when I lived in Florida like I had a
grill yeah and uh
that [ __ ] like you had to like take it
out clean it otherwise your mouth would
[ __ ] smell like funky yeah you think
oh man okay oh yeah I cleaned my grill
man that is nasty yeah I cleaned my
grill I'll try not to smoke any unless
I'm too drunk and I'm I'm just
belligerent what about eating in it
all right yeah that's trifling bro yeah
I feel bad for the guys to do like the
[ __ ] I was talking to see uh he's he's
got permanent teeth that's different
though no but he's he's he's he uh he's
removing him and going back to normal
teeth because he said it's just too much
maintenance it's got to be a lot of
Maintenance though because it'd be
diamonds too and it feels great like
your mouth feel your teeth feel it's not
as smooth you know what I'm saying but
nah that [ __ ] way if it ain't perms just
like you got it you guys you're gonna
not eat mm-hmm yeah
I like the wood green that's a really
that's original yeah man
eat it up
you already know that hey you know the
[ __ ] be they bit my last Grill
my opal Grill Kim Kardashian stole that
[ __ ] Lynn Isaacs who else uh had this
[ __ ] uh which girl was this a lot of
people it was opal grill with the uh the
bus now they know that you know it's a
little though
yeah he pulled up on me and said like
yeah man I got the you know what I'm
saying like I seen them it's cool that
[ __ ] hard but Kim Kardashian show me no
love so that's that's like I'm I just
want Kim K to just you know what I'm
saying just showed up I mean all her
grills for oh God I didn't I've never
seen her wearing a grill she put that
[ __ ] on bro it's an October Baby thing
you know opal like a birthstone I think
she a Libra do you think uh Kim
Kardashian wearing a grill is cultural
appropriation
at this point uh
nah like at this point uh when you say
at this point what do you mean it's just
at this point now like what like at this
point now it ain't like Kim Kardashian
wearing a girl is not shout out to Kim
too because I feel like she's done a lot
of good on the legal legal side to try
to get people out of jail oh yeah free
my uncle Kim on gang where you at cop
make it happen bro and free shorty Blood
please hmm I'll be good